also wir haben vielleicht helfe in den
letzten tagen als eine etwas andere
stadt mit etwas anderen leuten kennen
gelernt etwas gröber und etwas jahr
aggressiver als andere städte die ich
vorher kennengelernt habe als berliner
club man ja dass es nicht so viele
andere orte gibt die ja so robust und
grob und vielleicht noch unfreundlich
sind hier jetzt in philadelphia in den
letzten tagen haben wir erlebt dass es
noch der andere stadt gibt und was haben
die menschen hier gemacht sie haben sich
also einen donald trump was sagt
aufgebaut und diesen sack darf jetzt
jeder in der stadt einmal verprügeln a
jetzt kommen kommt der nächste junge
frau und ein stück weiter zu sagen dafür
zieht jeder seine wut sein hass und
eigene ärger aus den vergangenen vier
jahren raus lassen und das unter jubel
und geschrei der anderen menschen
ihr müsst euch vorstellen das geht jetzt
hier so seit einer stunde oder noch
länger hier stehen immer noch 56 700
leute die ich auch glaube ich alle noch
einmal zu stark ist kann noch mal rüber
schwenken
da kommt die nächste crew ein ganz
gewöhnlicher samstag in philadelphia ich
hab euch nicht zu viel versprochen
es deckt sich wirklich mit unserem
gefühl und mein gefühl ist auch das geht
ja noch ein paar stunden so für den
spektakulären westling motto mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bild schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren